We said there are two parts, we had to
define our access control policy and
then we have to do enforcement
based on what is in that policy.
Clearly that policy defines who can
access what and things like that.
That kind of information, we going to
abstract that in a data structure
that is called an Access Control Matrix,
or an ACM.
If it's a matrix,
in this case an access control matrix,
that is going to abstract all
the state that is relevant for
making those access control decisions.
Well matrixes have rows and columns.
To define a matrix you have to say
what rows it has, what kind of columns
it has, what does it store in each
element, or each cell of the matrix.
In an accesss control matrix,
rows are defined by the users or
subjects that we have in the group.
So rows actually correspond to the
sources of requests or the subjects or
the users.
So this access control matrix,
if Alice is a user in the system,
there is going to be a row for Alice.
Well other thing that a matrix
has is to define this two
dimensional matrix we are talking about
is we have to define its columns.
Rows correspond to users.
Actually columns going to correspond to
resources that we have in the system.
So each resource that
needs to be protected.
Remember, we need to know who
is allowed to access it or not.
So this matrix is sort of
telling you for a given user,
that's a row, and a given resource or
object, what can be done.
So the columns are going to
correspond to all the resources that
need to be protected in the system.
So an access control matrix, since I'm
talking about rows and columns and
it's two dimensions.
Any particular entry, or cell,
in this matrix can be defined
by what we have here, [U, O],
with the row that is corresponds to
user U and the column for object O.
You start with a user,
continue until you get to the object
that we are talking about.
So that element of the matrix or
cell of the matrix,
is actually going to define what kind of
access rights user U has for object O.
So if this was a file, and the access
rights can be read/write, execute or
whatever subset of those access
rights then we're saying the entry
in the matrix,
if you look at the row for user U and
object O, it's going to say if
you can read this object O.
R is present in that entry.
That means the user can
read object O's matrix.
Access control matrix is based
on users we have in the system,
resources we have in the system, and
the state actually it captures is
who had what kind of access for
the resources of the system.
That's what each entry of the matrix
is going to answer a question for
a given user and
a given object or resource.